j'ai une vie très intéressante il
m'arrive toujours des choses n'est pas
plus tard que cette nuit j'entends du
bruit je me dis tiens le chat doit être
sous le lit je me lève je regarde sous
lui qu'est ce que je trouve le chat
c'est intéressant
non plus fort encore tous les ans au
mois de juin et le rhume des foins set
allait geler maintenant ça change
elle accueille tous les matins se lèvent
à la même heure - jours-ci 19h45 le
lendemain 19h50 ya pas de règles
vendredi au lieu d'un art ans je me
ferais un merlan jamais la même chose
qu'elle fait la connaissance d'une femme
judy venait passer la soirée chez moi et
me répond non encore un souvenir
avant de charles artiste j'étais dans la
publicité un jour un client arrive ils
n'ont le monsieur qu'il est votre
problème dit voilà je voudrais j'aurais
monté un hôtel près d'une gare
je sais pas comment l'appeler lui dis
laissez moi réfléchir au bout d'une
heure lui dit monsieur vous voulez
monter un hôtel près d'une gare c'est
pas comme on l'appelait ap l'hôtel de la
poste intéressant qui a plus fort encore
toutes plus fort quand je fais la
connaissance de quelqu'un je dit
enchanté monsieur si c'est un homme et
en santé madame si c'est une femme
intéressante
puis j'ajoute doux et vous allez
comprendre pourquoi je fais votre
connaissance
encensé monsieur vous êtes un homme nous
êtes-vous mois pour les fruits du mans
dia oui les rillettes
alors vous êtes content ce que les votre
pays moi je suis content j'ai l'occasion
de montrer ma culture la glace est
rompue
georges fait la connaissance d'une femme
gît enchanté madame d'où êtes-vous et me
répond celui de roncevaux alors joué
parlé de rolland et son corps ça tombait
bien parce que c'est un sujet qui
n'intéresse personne à la maison ils ont
même poussé la méchanceté
quel bout c'est à cause des voisins j'ai
pas encore extraordinaire museau
entretient bien je lastic jeu le frotte
avec une peau de chamois et un corps
bienvenu on garde toute une vie et je
m'ennuie jamais mon corps quand je suis
triste je suis tout seul je trempe mon
corps dans l'eau et chacun sait que tout
coeur de chasse plongé dans un liquide
reçoit une poussée verticale égal au
poids du liquide déplacés
alors je regarde flatter mon corps est à
ce moment là je me demande si je ne suis
pas encore plus contre le dit